[Música]
dos altos funcionarios de la casa blanca
se reunirán en kiev con el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr celesc y el
mandatario reiteró que si las tropas
rusas matan a militares en mariupol no
habrá más negociaciones por otra parte
se intensifican los ataques aéreos en la
región del donbass y en el sur de
ucrania
ante 400 cadáveres fueron recogidos y
exhumados en el suburbio de butch a las
afueras de la capital ucraniana así lo
informó el alcalde anatoly fedor utah
ahora decenas de cuerpos esperan ser
reconocidos por sus familiares
israel cerrará el cruce con la franja de
gaza en respuesta al lanzamiento de
varios cohetes hacia suelo israelí los
enfrentamientos se enmarcan en la ola de
violencia en pleno ramadán ramadán en la
que han muerto al menos 29 palestinos y
14 israelíes analizaremos en esta misión
bienvenidos de nuevo a las noticias de
france 24 yo soy maría clara calle y es
un gusto estar con ustedes
empezamos con las noticias más recientes
de ucrania el presidente de ese país
volodymyr se les dio una rueda de prensa
en la que anunció que el secretario de
estado de eeuu anthony blinken y el
secretario de defensa austin irán a kiev
mañana domingo según el mandatario
hablarán de las armas que necesitan los
ucranianos y del ritmo de entrega
mientras que la casa blanca no dio
ningún pronunciamiento la visita es la
primera que hace el gobierno de
estadounidense luego de ser criticado
por no ir a ucrania a diferencia de lo
que han hecho varios líderes europeos se
les espera que el presidente de eeuu
vaya pronto y criticó que el secretario
de la onu antonio guterres vaya primero
a moscú que aquí es escuchemos lo que
dijo sobre el viaje de los
estadounidenses
no creo que sea un gran secreto aunque
no sé si es público todavía mañana llega
a gente de eeuu tendría una reunión con
el ministro de defensa del secretario de
estado el señor blinken lamblin quien ha
apoyado modo estamos esperando por
circunstancias de seguridad para
permitir que el presidente de eeuu
llegue y apoye a la nación ucraniana
víctima de crain's que además el
presidente volodymyr selenski reiteró
que dejarán de negociar con rusia si las
tropas enviadas por moscú matan a los
soldados que aún resisten en mariupol
hoy los militares rusos bombardearon de
nuevo la fábrica de acero de as hostal
en esa ciudad donde estaba atrincherado
el último foco de resistencia ucraniana
se le es que también advirtió que
rechazan un referendo en la ciudad de
gerzón que ya controlan los rusos
si nuestros hombres son asesinados en
mayo político y si estos pseudo
referéndum se organizan en nuevas pseudo
repúblicas entonces ucrania se retirará
de cualquier proceso de negocios
para el mundo el proceso por otra parte
los ataques han aumentado en la región
del donbass en el este ucraniano donde
se concentra la nueva fase de la
operación militar de los rusos el estado
mayor de las fuerzas armadas de ucrania
afirma que repelieron ocho ataques rusos
en lugansk y en donges que en las
últimas 24 horas por su parte de la
organización para la seguridad y la
cooperación en europa denunció que
varios de los miembros de su misión
nacional fueron retenidos en esas
provincias lado se precisó que están
intentando establecer canales de
comunicación para que sean liberados
en el sur ucraniano al menos cinco
personas murieron y 18 resultaron
heridas en un ataque con misiles en la
ciudad portuaria de odessa el comando
aéreo del sur de ucrania aseguró que los
misiles impactaron en una instalación
militar y en dos edificios residenciales
pero la versión de rusia es que el
objetivo del ataque fue únicamente un
depósito donde se guardaban armas
enviadas por eeuu y la unión europea
este ataque ocurre luego de que el
comandante adjunto del distrito militar
central de rusia afirmara que moscú
quiere controlar el sur de ucrania para
poder llegar hasta el territorio de
transnistria en moldavia es de dinero
una de nuestras enviadas especiales
leticia álvarez nos reportó cuál es la
importancia de lo que ocurre en odessa
el ejército ruso ha atacado la ciudad
portuaria de odessa dos misiles han
impactado contra un edificio de
viviendas y un edificio militar hay
cinco fallecidos o de esa es una ciudad
clave para este país apenas había sido
atacada tiene más de 800 mil habitantes
y es muy significativo este lanzamiento
de misiles porque se produce horas
después de que un alto cargo militar
ruso avisara de que odessa está bajo el
punto de mira porque quieren controlar
todo ese flanco sur el ministro de
exteriores culé va denunciado que estos
ataques forman parte de una campaña para
aterrorizar a todos los ciudadanos de
este país de forma simultánea también ha
sido atacado la ciudad de kharkiv que es
frente de batalla y a quién ni pero
dónde nos encontramos las defensas
antiaéreas se han derribado un misil
justo en el parque que tenemos a
nuestras espaldas donde han caído los
fragmentos a esa hora el parque estaba
abierto
alcaldía de butch afirmó que al menos
412 cuerpos fueron exhumados y ahora
están en las morgues esperando ser
identificados en este suburbio a las
afueras de kiev cuando las autoridades
ucranianas denunciaron que cientos de
personas fueron torturadas y luego
asesinadas en medio de la retirada de
las tropas rusas un señalamiento que
moscú ha negado ahora los residentes se
dedican a buscar los cuerpos de sus
seres queridos
después del horror una nueva prueba para
los residentes de butch a montones de
bolsas con cuerpos frente a la morgue
esperan identificación para los
familiares puede ser el final de un
largo viaje nadie a kovalenko encontró
los restos de su hija ella había ido a
buscar agua para llevar a casa cuando
murió en un bombardeo el
estriado cable de luz
tranquila se acabó
como funcionaria electa me caí lin a
ayuda a las familias en duelo pero
también conoce de primera mano el dolor
de perder a un ser querido después de
que su marido muriera luchando en el
donbass my name now estoy out mi
objetivo ahora es ayudar a cada familia
a encontrar a todos sus parientes y como
ayuntamiento de lucha es muy importante
para nosotros enterrar a todos de forma
adecuada por fin el propio rey tania ha
estado buscando el cuerpo de su esposo
durante las últimas dos semanas todo lo
que sabe es que podría estar en lucha o
en una morgue en un pueblo cercano a
maestros de música lo más terrible de mi
vida es que mi esposo ni amado se ha ido
no sé que podría ser peor buscar entre
los cadáveres ya no me asusta en
comparación con la tragedia en mi vida
solo en muchas cientos de personas
fueron asesinadas y torturadas por los
rusos según funcionarios ucranianos el
número de víctimas podría llegar a ser
mucho mayor en todo el país cerca de
mariupol recientemente se descubrieron
dos fosas comunes como esta
cambiamos de noticia israel cerrará su
cruce fronterizo con la franja de gaza
lo que impide que 12.000 trabajadores
palestinos que tienen permisos para
cruzar por el paso de erez ya no pueden
ir a trabajar a suelo israelí el
organismo militar de israel que controla
los asuntos civiles en gaza anunció que
la reapertura dependerá de una
evaluación de seguridad el cruce se
cerró luego de que militantes palestinos
dispararan tres misiles entre el viernes
y el sábado hacia territorio israelí la
más reciente tensión comenzó hace un mes
con una serie de ataques en israel y
luego con las redadas del ejército en
cisjordania al menos 14 israelíes y 29
palestinos han muerto para hablar del
tema conectamos con luis alberto
villamarín coronel retirado del ejército
colombiano e investigador especializado
en geopolítica de medio oriente y asia
meridional señor villamarín bienvenido a
france 24 explíquenos cómo han escalado
las recientes tensiones entre los
israelíes y los palestinos al punto de
cerrar el cruce con gas
buenas tardes maría clara muy amable
publicitación esto se ha complicado
porque parecería hacer que es el
comienzo de una nueva intifada
infortunadamente la coincidencia del
ramadán con la fiesta que ocurre cada 33
años y que las tres religiones se
encuentran y lo que ocurrió la semana
anterior el viernes pasado que las
fuerzas israelíes se vieron obligadas a
entrar al templo del monte o al templo a
la explanada o como lo llaman los
musulmanes la mezquita la explanada y
exacerbó los ánimos y trajo la situación
a este nivel de que en los últimos ocho
días hubo siete días de confrontación y
parece que esto va a seguir prolongando
y la medida de apretar a los
trabajadores genera más tensiones
y precisamente esos ataques contra la
mezquita de la explanada fueron los que
desencadenaron la guerra de 11 días del
año pasado que tan cerca podríamos estar
de una guerra como la de ese entonces
infortunadamente maría clara muy cerca
porque es que las tensiones como se
viven allá y en especial ahí cerquita en
el en la ciudad oriental
es muy es un ambiente muy pesado y
cuando ocurre una actividad de estas
inmediatamente cierran las carreteras
hacia
nazaret o hacia hebrón y se comienzan
esos enfrentamientos callejeros y vienen
los choques y los jóvenes que sienten
que su futuro no es muy claro y que les
han metido tanta cosa en la cabeza se
extienden y con la presencia de los
colonos en la cisjordania peor todavía
porque la situación se complica más y
como hay unas personas que guardan la
línea del señor beteta en yahoo entonces
se multiplican esos odios y las
tensiones parecería tender a que podría
repetirse lo al año pasado y como le
decía al principio para que se
desarrolle una nueva intifada que es
prácticamente una guerra abierta y
permanente y la franja de casa tiene un
bloqueo por parte de israel y de egipto
desde hace más de 15 años desde que
hamás tomó el poder en ese contexto
qué tanto afecta el cierre de la
frontera
afecta para entrar a israel mano a
egipto porque en egipto lo que hicieron
fue de destruir una parte de la ciudad
de rafáh o rafa y dejar un espacio donde
sean los túneles pero es que sea esa
historia de los túneles es eterna maría
clara cuando uno está allá eso existe a
diario que están descubriendo los y sale
uno y aparece otro porque hay unas
mafias alrededor y en la parte ya donde
pasan de gaza a israel o sea el oriente
el problema es el temor de la seguridad
y como han ocurrido tantas situaciones
entonces los soldados israelíes se ven
presionados y de vez en cuando aparecen
la yihad islámica o el vino a más
lanzando cohetes y en este momento e
irán desafortunadamente por medio de su
parque hezbollah y las guerrillas que
están al sur del líbano y el siria está
apoyando e instigando a que se forme un
conflicto mayor y de paso israel no
perdona objetivo que detecta en síria
entonces las tensiones son permanentes y
se podría repetir una intifada con
resultados impredecibles
alberto villamarín gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 ahora cambiamos de
noticia y vamos a áfrica porque más de
100 personas murieron en nigeria por la
explosión en una refinería de petróleo
ilegal el comisionado estatal de
recursos petroleros goodluck obvian
explicó que todo comenzó por un incendio
en el abastecimiento de combustible
ilegal en el estado sureño de rivers que
ustedes ven en sus pantallas según el
centro de defensa de la juventud y el
medio ambiente varios vehículos que
estaban en una fila para comprar
gasolina se quemaron en octubre hubo un
accidente similar en otra refinería
ilegal en nigeria y que provocó la
muerte de 25 personas
se reportó un nuevo caso de ébola en
república democrática del congo es el
primero desde que la organización
mundial de la salud declaró el fin del
último brote de esta enfermedad en el
país el caso fue confirmado por el
instituto nacional de investigaciones
biológicas y se reportó en la ciudad
norteña de mbandaka la capital de la
provincia de equateur con esto resurge
en república democrática del congo un
virus que desde el 16 de diciembre de
2021 ya se había controlado el último
brote que fue el decimotercero de la
nación produjo 11 casos y 6 muertos en
la provincia nororiental de kivú del
norte y entre el 2018 y 2020 el ébola
mató a cerca de 2.300 personas en ese
país según la ong sin embargo las
autoridades hacen un llamado a la calma
ante este nuevo caso
en menos de 24 horas
francia elegirá quien ocupará la
presidencia durante los próximos 5 años
mañana domingo casi 49 millones de
franceses podrán acudir a las urnas en
la segunda vuelta electoral en vísperas
de estos comicios algunos municipios
carecen de asesores se trata de
voluntarios que velan por el buen
funcionamiento de los colegios
electorales y son esenciales para el
proceso aquí les contamos
en los colegios electorales las
papeletas y las urnas están listas pero
al igual que la primera vuelta faltan
asesores que ayuden a atender las mesas
necesitamos dos asesores por colegio
electoral tenemos 70 colegios
electorales en la ciudad y hay muchos en
los que sólo hay un asesor lo mismo
ocurre en verdad en dordoña en los
últimos días hemos tenido cancelaciones
por casos de cobijo min
también es cierto que el tiempo que se
realiza la segunda vuelta no es muy
bueno en términos de calendario tres
zonas estarán de vacaciones al mismo
tiempo en francia los asesores se eligen
de tres maneras entre los representantes
de los partidos políticos entre los
votantes locales o entre los
funcionarios locales como en el caso de
berriz donde el alcalde y pidió a un
administrador municipal que ayudara en
un colegio electoral
siempre es interesante poder participar
en este tipo de operaciones ver desde
dentro cómo se celebran unas elecciones
las normas del código electoral son
estrictas además de los dos asesores se
necesitan un presidente y un secretario
para gestionar las urnas la escasez de
voluntarios suele provocar una mayor
espera para los votantes
llegamos al final de las noticias sigan
con nosotros en france 24
[Música]